elvis lebt meine damen und herren die
mondlandung war inszeniert und hinter
den anschlägen des 11 september 2001
stecken achtung die usa selbst
derzeit erleben wir eine renaissance von
solchen verschwörungstheorien
aber warum blumen sie gerade heute woher
kommt das gefühl wir würden von dunklen
mächten an der nase herumgeführt und
können die überhaupt trennscharf
unterscheiden zwischen
verschwörungstheorie und war hand
darüber spreche ich mit der
kulturwissenschaftlerin eva horn
sie ist professorin an der universität
wien und expertin für verschwörungen
ebenso wie für den weltuntergang und die
zerstreuen
er ist präsident von info sektor und
psychologe info sektor ist die zürcher
fachstelle für sektenfragen frauen
erstaunlich herzlich willkommen danke er
hat zunächst eine persönliche frage sind
sie auch schon mal ein anhörungs theorie
auf den leim gegangen
glaube ich hab nach nine eleven eine
zeit lang mit vielleicht etwas zu viel
interesse stückchen
verschwörungstheorien verfolgt ich fand
das interessant und habe nach der ganzen
relativ tief schürfenden beschäftigung
mit diesen unmengen von fakten
irgendwann gesagt so jetzt habe ich so
viele fakten geschäft jetzt weiß ich das
war nicht das was die
verschwörungstheoretiker glauben also
eine zeit lang habe ich den den streng
verfolgt um dann fest davon überzeugt zu
sein als die verschwörungstheorien
falsch sind
was hat den ausschlag gegeben noch nie
na ja es gab eben sehr sehr viele
es gab sofort diese offizielle fassung
der der regierung also das sind diese
diese al qaida verschwörer und die haben
diese riesen operation geplant und man
wusste nicht genau wer eigentlich zu
sowas auch von der infrastruktur her in
der lage waren die 19 männer mit messer
und es war halt eine völlig neue form
auch der flugzeug entführung und so
weiter und weil das so neuber hatte man
natürlich von vornherein so ein bisschen
den verdacht die die kamen zu schnell
eigentlich mit schuldigen auf das schon
praktisch am tag selbst da wussten die
aha mohammed atta sind papiere gefunden
worden
das war so good to be true und das hat
sofort und eigentlich auch bei vielen
klugen leuten im internet so eine fülle
von eigentlich fragen aufgeworfen und
was ich interessant fand war das eben
fragen gestellt werden an die offizielle
version die von der bush-regierung
vorgetragen wurde und ich habe diese
fragen weiter verfolgt das fand ich
faszinierend
er streute bei ihm sind sie mal einer
verschwörungstheorie muss mich ständig
ein bisschen dagegen wehren ständig wenn
ich zeitung lese und dann über zeitungs
hat die geräte dann blickt mich meine
frau macht noch ein bisschen komisch an
und er merklich ich fange schon wieder
an nicht zu begeistern für irgendwelche
theorien die wahrscheinlich rheine
xing das ist es umso und dann war's ja
ich meine so stars promis da gibt es
ständig meldungen oder auch empörte
artikel über sachen die passiert sind
und dann merke ich sie sagt dann du
genießt das glaube ich ein bisschen zu
sehr aber ich habe von den persönlich
gelesen dass sie mal ein ufo
entführungen ja da habt da hab ich
meinen kurzen moment schwach das war
aber auch eine tolle story es dass die
aliens in unserem schlafzimmer kommen
und wir dann zum fenster raus weben das
haben sie geglaubt ja so kann man das
nicht sagen aber ich fand die
geschichten einfach ungeheuer
faszinieren vielleicht wünscht man sich
dass sogar ja dann ist noch ein
mechanismus dran wenn man seine
geschichte liest stellt man sich das ja
bildlich vor
das heißt man ist eine show im film
trinken und dann ist es vielleicht schon
ein bisschen passiert muss man zuerst
wieder raus
wenn man eine sehr lebendige vorstellen
jahr kraft bevor wir uns genau anschauen
was verschwörungstheorien sind wie sie
funktionieren und warum sie uns so
faszinieren haben wir kurz zurück im
historischen rückblick einige theorien
mit bildern am 22 november 63 präsident
john f kennedy wird in dallas erschossen
der täter lee harvey oswald ein
einzeltäter indizien deuten auf einen
zweiten schützen ist es der cia die
mafia exil kubaner oder alle zusammen
erzeugen deren aussagen von der
offiziellen version abweichen sterben
auf mysteriöse weise und als oswald
ermordet wird nimmt auch er sein
geheimnis mit ins grab
31 august 97 paris die letzten stunden
der prinzessin ein mercedes ein pfeiler
das ende alles nur ein unfall verliert
der fahrer die herrschaft über den wagen
oder bringt ihn etwas von der spur ab
eine bombe ein anderes auto die
hintermänner eines möglichen
mordkomplotts die königin die
minenindustrie oder des secret service
sechzehnter juli 69 start zur apollo 11
mission die welt schaut gebannt zu als
der amerikaner neil armstrong als erster
mensch den mond betreten
aber ist er wirklich auf dem mond oder
[Musik]
wird die landung in einem großen
filmstudio groß simuliert apollo 11
nichts als ein gigantischer werbespot
für die nasa und die usa august 62
marilyn monroe muss sie sterben weil sie
über ihre verhältnisse mit john und
robert kennedy auspacken will
april 94 curt cobain ist es selbstmord
obwohl auf der tatwaffe keine
fingerabdrücke sind oder hat seine frau
courtney love einen killer auf ihn
angesetzt juli 47 rosberg ist es ein ufo
das dort abstürzt wissen die usa mehr
über die existenz von außerirdischen und
verheimlichen es der öffentlichkeit
august 77 elvis presley lebt er noch
die wahrheit sie ist irgendwo dort
draußen ja
der beitrag ist schon ein bisschen älter
das ging dann weiter 2001 mit meinem
leben dann liegen die chemtrails die
idee das irgendwie kondensstreifen dass
flugzeuge chemie verbreiten die
klimalüge usw
da wir müssen erklären was überhaupt
eine verschwörungstheorie ist gibt es so
etwas wie eine akzeptable definition
also ja in der forschung gibt es
eigentlich einen konsens in der
verschwörungstheorie ist eine theorie
die erklärt dass ein historisches
ereignis
sozusagen von einer kleinen gruppe von
eingeweihten im geheim durchgeführt
wurde und sozusagen eine andere version
offiziell verbreitet wird das heißt
verschwörungstheorien sind eigentlich
meistens theorien der macht und zwar
einer geheimen macht strippenzieher die
im geheimen agieren und die sozusagen
dann eine eine coverstory darüber
breiten und verschwörungstheorien haben
immer und das ist eigentlich auch ganz
interessant
die tendenz sozusagen offizielle
wahrheiten zu hinterfragen und auf diese
diese dieses komplott durchgreifen zu
wollen
man könnte sagen macht und wissen was
wissen wir haben dann unterdrückt es
gibt ein geheimnis oder ich würde sagen
gibt verschwörungstheorien neben diesen
inhaltlichen definitionen sind auch ein
denkstil oder eine bestimmte psychische
haltung und gegen die rutschen wir ist
an mir selber gezeigt habe relativ
leicht rein dann ist plötzlich alles
klar
und es ist faszinierend es ist nicht
diese blöde gewöhnliche geschichte in
der wir sind sondern es wird aufregend
ist schon irgendwie kosmisch spannende
geschichte auf den denkst dient auf die
haltung hat das psychologische kommen
wir noch mal zu sprechen
der begriff wird ja oft abwertend
verwendeten dann sagt das nur eine
verschwörungstheorie und infizierte mir
dass es falsch ist aber ihre definition
gemäß können diese theorien auch wahr
sein richtig sei ja aber sie haben
vollkommen recht der begriff ist also
leicht gesagt eine
verschwörungstheoretiker rinn
dann ist das kein kompliment das ist
aber historisch nicht immer so gewesen
das neunzehnte jahrhundert und auch noch
teile des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
vielleicht sogar die ganze erste hälfte
da gibt es sehr viele offiziell
akzeptierte theorien darüber dass es
sozusagen dunkle hintermänner
seilschaften gruppierungen gibt die
sozusagen hinter dem schirm der
offiziellen ereignisse eigentlich die
die geschicke der der politik der
wirtschaft usw lenken
eine typische theorie ist die die
fiktion von der jüdischen
weltverschwörung aber es gibt natürlich
auch dann also sowohl der marxistische
kapitalistische verschwörungen der
großkonzerne und so weiter das sind
alles verschwörungstheorien die lange
zeit sehr akzeptiert waren und wo man
sich eigentlich nicht schämen musste
verschwörungstheoretiker zu sein
das hat sich in den 60 er jahren des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts dann
geändert auch mit einem text sehr sehr
wichtig war von hofstetter für paranoid
style in american politics der
beschreibt eben auf einmal
verschwörungstheorien als paranoia also
eigentlich als geistige störung als ein
denkstil der kurzschlüsse produziert
aber erst seit dieser zeit ist das
wirklich sozusagen etwas was man besser
nicht tun sollte
das sind die pathologische richtung
gehen hätte wobei ist das spiel
natürlich gibt eben genau in der
geschichte immer wieder jetzt auf dem
seit dem 19
juni ist was ganz spezielles online
nämlich ein webprojekt dh die
weltherrschaft und das ist koproduziert
von orf von esther es von arte und dem
bayerischen rundfunk und es soll uns so
müssen zeigen die verschwörungstheorien
funktionieren und hier auf der webseite
sieht man jetzt schon das ist ein
interaktiver video baukasten wo man
seine eigene verschwörungstheorie
basteln kann und wir können das kurz mal
zusammen machen das ist das ganze ist
eher ironisch witzig satirisch gemeint
klick auf play
man muss nämlich dann vier
entscheidungen treffen da spielen
erstens man muss überlegen wer ist denn
eigentlich der verschwörer oder die
gruppe der verschwörer und da kann man
jetzt auswählen zwischen ganz chorälen
optionen zwischen hauskatzen clowns und
so weiter ich nehme zwar die hauskatzen
clique weiter dann wird erläutert dass
jede verschwörungstheorie auch ein ziel
braucht also was verfolgen die welchen
plan haben die und hier nehme ich mal
das schlimmste den dritten weltkrieg
wahrscheinlich wie die katzen das machen
dann haben die immer eine bestimmte
methode wie sie vorgehen
mal schauen was man hier wählen kann
manipulation der medien
ich nehme mal die biologischen mittel
sagen wie die katzen das anstellen und
schließlich der beweis dafür dass diese
theorie stimmt oder stimmen könnte hier
nehme ich das jetzt sieht man eine
geheime studie die es vielleicht gebe
ich nehme das historische beispiel aus
dass katzen schon in der vergangenheit
immer die menschen irgendwie beeinflusst
haben also genau und jetzt errechnete er
das und wir schauen uns jetzt gemeinsam
an was dabei welche verschwörungstheorie
da rausgekommen ist wir stehen sehen
dass hier auf den bildschirmen die
vieles silvestris katus die familie der
hauskatzen
sie sind auf der ganzen welt zu hause
und in jeder kultur vertreten
sie werden von ihren besitzern geliebt
und verwöhnt man könnte fast meinen die
menschheit wäre ihnen zu diesen
beruht diese hingabe auf gegenseitigkeit
keinesfalls bei genauerer betrachtung
wird klar dass die niedlichen vierbeiner
einen perfiden plan verfolgen und es
geht ihnen um nichts geringeres als die
weltherrschaft
nichts käme denn felidae gelegener als
ein dritter weltkrieg ein bewaffneter
konflikt von globalem ausmaß würde die
bestehenden von menschen geschaffenen
macht konstellationen auf der erde in
windeseile auflösen
übrig bleiben würde nur eine kleine
gruppe gefühliger zweibeiner darauf
trainiert ihr neuen herrschern jeden
wunsch von den augen abzulesen
katzen bilder werden im netz häufiger
angeklickt als pornos kein wunder katzen
kontrollieren das internet um den
dritten weltkrieg anzustoßen werden die
katzen für einen massiven anstieg
niedliche social media postings sorgen
ein derart überlastetes internet wird
kraftwerke raketensilos und
kreditkartenunternehmen zum erliegen
bringen
im chaos versunken wird der mensch zur
waffe greifen um seine ressourcen zu
verteidigen die geschichte lehrt uns
dass die hauskatze stets die nähe von
aggressoren gesucht hat um tod und
zerstörung in die welt hinauszutragen
wie kamen die viecher denn vor circa
1000 jahren nach nord und mitteleuropa
auch wikinger schiffen im
schulterschluss mit mördern plündern und
vergewaltigen
im blutrausch fegten sie über unseren
kontinent und säten chaos ohne mit den
schnur hahn zu zucken
das sollte uns doch zu denken geben
experten sind sich einig das ende ist
nah ja sie sehen schon das ist sehr
satirisch gemacht und ich beeindruckt
diese verschwörung hat bereits
stattgefunden denn die menschen sind
tatsächlich billigen die wieder ihre
hauskatze so schlecht ja für sie zu
hause
sie können das natürlich auch machen auf
dieser webseite die weltherrschaft
können ihre eigene verschwörungstheorie
zusammenstellung ich kann das sehr
empfehlen wie gesagt das ist satirisch
aber man lernt trotzdem was dabei und
derzeit ist noch einen dokumentarfilm
ihm entstehen den wir srf anfang
september auf diesem sender zeigen auch
sehr lohnenswert ja das ist jetzt sehr
lustig aber verschwörungstheorien können
ja auch gefährlich sein
herr streuli ja sie sehen zwietracht die
grenzen ganze bevölkerungsgruppen aus
indem sie den zu schreiben die
weltherrschaft anstreben zu wollen uns
manipulieren zu wollen
und im geheimen eben die
machtverhältnisse ändern zu wollen naja
was ihre katzen sehen sind dann halt in
der realität die jugend gegen alsleben
her oder komisch sagt und und sie haben
das denken weil wenn dieser schalter
umgelegt wird und man im
verschwörungstheoretiker modus
funktioniert dann ist ja eben alles klar
und dann hört man sozusagen auf kritisch
zu sein und wirklich zu forschen
erklären was passiert ist sagen also
wird ein schalter umgelegt
das ist das bild bis zu dem ich bis
heute vorgedrungen bin was meinen sie
damit
man denkt plötzlich ganz anders also ist
psychisch gebrochen
es brauche muss man gleich sagen ihm
unbewussten ja das aktiviert was ja klar
konnte im großen anderen lenkt der
glaube dass es irgendwie eine macht gibt
die relevant ist
nur sagt locken sagt diesen platz für
den großen anderen gibt es bei allen von
uns am besten bleibt der lehrer aber
eben wir hatten als kinder schon unsere
eltern zu legen wir auf schauten zurecht
oder gebrauchten sie und wir hatten
idole und so weiter also dies auch
dieser platz ist wichtig ist der gott
der religion auch sowas vielleicht ist
er noch etwas anderes aber dass sie
theologische aussage ich spreche jetzt
vom psychologischen strukturen und wenn
dieser schalter umgelegt wird dann das
funktioniert auch so beim mobbing aber
im fundamentalismus dann hört man auch
wirklich selbst trägt ich vorhin zu sein
das klingt so ein bisschen pathologie
sie rennt ja irgendwie zu sagen der
werden schalter umgelegt es ist jemand
irrational geworden blendet er wichtige
informationen die haus so naja aber es
gilt auch für mich also ich bin nicht
eine bestimmte wieder bevölkerungsgruppe
dass wir alle anfällig sind für das mehr
oder weniger
ja ich würde da unterscheiden zwischen
verschwörungstheorien die genau so
funktionieren wie sie das beschrieben
haben verschwörungstheorien die
sozusagen auf eingeschlossen ist
bild bild rauslaufen und eine ganz
massive fein projektion haben dieser
große andere von dem sie gesprochen
haben der überall dahinter steckt die
strippen zieht und dann ist das dann
entsteht sozusagen eine völlig kohärente
wählt die auch keine zufälle mehr kennt
oder kontingent so die diese welt wird
relativ einfach was ich trotzdem
interessant finde an
verschwörungstheorien zb wie die
verschwörungstheorie nach nine eleven
und auch die verschwörungstheorien das
kam ja auch im einspieler nach der
ermordung von john f kennedy
das waren ja er versuche hinter eine
wahrheit zu kommen die tatsächlich nicht
adressiert werden konnte
man hatte diesen lohn gunman den
einzeltäter lee harvey oswald und das
ist wenn man sich den tathergang genauer
anschaut einfach in hohem maße
unplausibel und dann wird der mann auch
noch schnell erschossen um nicht mal
mehr aussagen zu können ich fand es
vollkommen richtig dass da leute in den
usa gesagt haben moment mal
der report die erste große untersuchung
dieses tathergangs ist eine einzige
schlamperei die eigentlich nur praktisch
funktioniert wie eine anklageschrift
gegen lee harvey oswald alternative
theorien werden nicht gesucht und da ist
verschwörungstheorie eigentlich ein
versuch hinter eine offizielle redeweise
zu kommen das heißt ich finde
verschwörungstheorien dann interessant
wenn sie fragen stellen und wenn sie
offizielle versionen in frage stellen
und in der hinsicht haben sie auch eine
große produktivität wenn sie anfangen
ein geschlossenes weltbild zu
produzieren mit find gruppen zu
argumentieren dann werden sie eben nicht
nur tendenziell paranoid sondern
natürlich auch politischen hohem maße
gefährlich
also da muss man glaube ich
unterscheiden zwischen der produktiven
kraft von verschwörungstheoretikern
fragen man will ja mal fragen oder einem
bestimmten skeptizismus gegenüber der
öffentlichen öffentlich vorgetragen war
und eben diesen paranoiden frauen
gesundes gesundes misstrauen ein zweifel
ein verdacht an der offiziellen version
werden sie sagen kann sogar vorbild
charakter kann das hab ich schon ein
versteuern
zum beispiel der investigative
journalismus der machenschaft
klüngeleien korruption aufdeckt das ist
ja was ganz wichtig ist und da müssen
zuerst hypothesen gehandelt werden die
noch nicht bewiesen sind dass man
misstrauen hatte und dann plötzlich auf
etwas stößt was relativ massiv oder welt
gespannt sein kann
das ist aber nicht eine
verschwörungstheorie weil dort fehlt
dass das genießen das kosmische das ist
immer aufregend der lehrling eigentlich
fast zum teufel selbst bisschen
übertrieben seien
dazu müssten sie sprechen von einer
angst los oder von einem jahr von einer
lust am schauen sie sehr haben oder am
bösen und das muss man das müssen
verschwörungstheoretiker enke schon
ihren ansichten muss etwas aufregendes
werden was gibt es sonst noch für motive
schauen wir mal ein bisschen weiter also
oft wird ja gesagt eben diesen diesem
zufall ausschauen das braucht eine
erklärung es dürfen nicht irgendwelche
prozesse sein sondern es muss ein plan
dahinter stehen ein operatives master
palmas naja jetzt noch mal von der
seiten seite der konsumenten von der sie
ja ausgehen also wer sind die leute die
an verschwörungstheorien glauben ist
glaube ich ein ganz wichtiges motiv das
ist eigentlich abgehängt zu sein oder
ausgegrenzt sich zu fühlen das nicht
keine souveränität sein ich habe das
gefühl irgendetwas stimmt hier nicht
mir geht es nicht gut ich fühle mich
sozial nicht anerkannt ich fühle mich
nicht berücksichtigt nicht adressiert
und in dieser situation frage ich warum
ist das so also man kann das auch auf
die einfache warum passieren guten
menschen blöde sachen und dann fange ich
an zu fragen was könnte dahinterstecken
das kann doch nicht alles zufall sein
und da gibt es sicherlich diesen moment
vielleicht nicht des genießens aber des
trosts ich weiß auf einmal der steckt
ein
ein agent dahinter also 1 1 eine
intention das ist nicht einfach zu fall
und ich muss mich beklagen das ist halt
dumm gelaufen ist sondern ich kann
jemanden finden der an meinem unglück
schuld es und das ist ein historisch
auch ganz ganz altes motiv das sich auch
also schon durch durch sagen wir mal
frühe moderne also frühneuzeitliche zb
hexen glauben und und denunziationen
wegen wegen schwarze magie und so weiter
zieht warum hat der hagel mainfeld
zerstört weil der nachbar ein zauber
über mich belegt hat ich will erklären
warum es mir schlecht gegangen ist und
vor allem entschuldigen man ja mal
fragen der schuldig ist und sagen diese
uhr gemacht dass man kann leider auch
vernichten und so den die ursache der
schweizer historiker philipp sache sind
spricht auch von ein trost eine deutung
was irgendwie gibt es trost da man dann
irgend dieses dieses dieses ereignis
anfang an für sich irgendwie einordnen
kann in amberg wird meine ich fühle mich
ja auch ziemlich bedroht ich lebe in
einer internet welt die welt des google
microsoft und viele andere
und ich merke immer dass die mit meinen
daten
sehr seltsam umgehen dass sie ihren
gewinn vergrößerung mit meinen daten usw
das fernsehen ist auch da also irgendwo
lebe ich in einer welt die
undurchsichtig ist und wo ich zu wenig
informationen habe um zu verstehen was
da alles für datenflüsse und kein flüsse
sich ereignet die mit mir zu tun haben
könnte ich schon verschwörer verfügungs
theoretisch werden kann man aus
psychologischer sicht sagen wer dann
besonders anfällig ist also sie haben
jetzt eine einige charakteristika gehört
eben dieses ohnmachtsgefühle sich
ausgeschlossen sein abgehängt sein
gibt es andere zum beispiel der junge
menschen eher alte männer frauen gibt es
einen unterschied also die statistiken
die ich kenne sei aber vielleicht kennen
sie andere sagen dass es vor allen
dingen männer über 40 sind
ich weiß nicht ich tue mich immer ein
bisschen schwer mit diesem fest nagel
ungen von bestimmten gruppierungen weil
das hat auch immer sowas bisschen
herablassendes ne also im letzten
amerikanischen wahlkampf gab es ja auch
immer wieder den vorwurf trump wähler
sind verschwörungstheoretiker
dumpfbacken ungebildet weiße männer und
das ist einfach überhaupt kein valida
erklärungs zugang ich glaube man muss
dann schon inhaltliche kriterien
entwickeln aus welchen gründen
herausfinden leute verschwörungstheorien
interessant und begeistern sich für sie
und teilen sie mit gerade jetzt auch
über die über die sozialen netzwerke wie
zirkulieren die das ist glaube ich
wichtiger als zu sagen da gibt es
bestimmte gruppen die sind anfällig ich
glaube jeder mensch erlebt in seinem
leben das mal das gefühl hier passiert
mir was ganz übles und ich habe keine
ahnung woher das kommt und warum das so
ist ich verliere meinen job und das ist
nicht nur irgendwie dass ich mich mit
dem chef gestritten habe sondern es lief
alles guten plötzlich verliere ich den
man kann sagen ja das sind strukturelle
prozesse die stadt finde aber ich kann
auch anfangen dafür sozusagen ein
causales muster zu entwickeln sagen das
passiert mir das passiert anderen und
dafür gibt's benennbar schuldige und die
frage ist eigentlich während in welcher
situation machen dass leute aber ich
glaube jeder von uns
sie würde verschwörungstheoretiker
werden wenn ihm nur genug übles zu
stress ja es gab mal in der
neuropsychologie eine untersuchung die
eine population herausgestellt hat die
einen mann mehr magisches denken zu
gestalten hat und das bedeutet diese
leute assoziieren viel leichter als
andere
ich gehe ganz sicher dazu als sie das
meist mehr ein stichwort ihm steckt oder
mit ideen filmen fernsehserien womit man
das phänomen illustrieren können
ich habe aber auch ein skeptisches bein
standbein oder ich bin nicht so sicher
ob das so relevant ist weil ich eben
denke es ist eher etwas was
eingeschaltet ist oder ausgeschaltet ist
bei uns allen
ich fand's wagen weil ich habe es nicht
so erlebt also ist in vorbereitung auf
die sendung habe ich ein bisschen rein
gelesen ich kannte diese theorien nicht
über jetzt in dem mond landen oder nine
eleven und die meine persönliche
erfahrung ist je mehr man liest desto
spannender wird das desto glaubwürdiger
wird das irgendwie und studien zeigen
nach wissen schützt überhaupt nicht also
leute die sehr klug sind und sehr viel
wissen die sind genauso anfällig das
zahlt was zeigt dass vielleicht zeigt
das dass dadurch die topstars
es erzeugt also gerade sogar relativ
interessant und komplizierte
verschwörungstheorien wie die mainova
gefaked nine eleven war ein inside job
gfk se oder die russen oder wer auch
immer die mafia die erzeugen ein
alternatives expertentum man wird dann
wirklich zum experten ich wurde
zeitweilig zu zur expertin für die bau
technik die die ab wann bricht
stahlbeton bei welcher temperatur
auseinander und so weiter aus
literaturwissenschaftlerin und
kulturwissenschaften also es gibt ein
expertentum dass sich daran dann an
anlagert und das erzeugt eigentlich
immer mehr wissen und nicht immer
weniger wissen oder der sa bruder film
der also während der schüsse auf john f
kennedy gedreht wurde des einzelnen
frame auseinander gelegt worden und es
gibt also experten für einzelne frames
das heißt verschwörungstheorien
bestimmte verschwörungstheorien sind
nichts für dumpfbacken also man muss
unheimlich viel
ich würde aber auch da es gibt solche
und solche verschwörungstheorien es gibt
auch verschwörungstheorien die finde ich
in der letzten zeit zirkulieren
die die flattern sowieso eine
eintagsfliege durch den medien zyklus
und sind dann wieder weg und eigentlich
erhebt auch keiner den anspruch dass
noch belegen zu wollen
okay das ist ein neues will dass das
würde ich sagen ist absolut neu und sie
ein beispiel nennen ich kenne spitzer
geld haben sie von killergames den teils
habe ich auch nicht mehr also peter geht
war ein gerücht das glaube ich diesen
frühling lanciert wurde dass hillary
clinton in einer pizzeria in washington
dc also in dem keller dieser pizzeria
ein studio unterhält wo
kinderpornografie stattfindet sehr
plausibel
also die welt ist habe ich mir nie
anders vorgestellt
und es ist tatsächlich jemand dann in
die in frage stehende pizzeria und
hinein in einem mcdonald's gewesen um
sich für diese kinderpornografischen
aktivitäten hillary clinton zu rechnen
und hat in diesem mcdonald's
herumgeballert in washington dc das
heißt es gab also jemand der mit
waffengewalt dargestellt hat dass er an
diese geschichte glaubt daran haben
sicherlich nicht viele leute geglaubt es
an absurdität nicht zu überbieten
dennoch zirkulieren diese sachen auch
durch die alternativen medien und werden
weitergegeben von leuten ja also das
meine ich mit vollkommen absurden
theorien die niemand belegen
die von denen man längst das dreht sich
eine woche im kreis und aber das ist
glaube ich ein neuer stand der dinge
aber sie sprechen ganz wichtigen punkt
dann wenn ich doch sagen dass noch sagen
darf also diesen neuen medien die social
media insbesondere und was dann steht
sind da diese echo kammern oder diese
filter blasen und da gibt es ein effekt
den der in der psychologie sehr bekannt
ist nehmen sich dieses dieser
bestätigungs irrtum der konfirmation
byers und der wird immer stärker was das
ist schauen wir uns ganz kurzen in einem
einspieler der mechanismus am beispiel
eines klima skeptikern was seine meinung
widerlegt blendet der tendenziell aus
was ihn bestätigt nimmt er stärker war
so wird seine überzeugung immer noch
stärker der konfirmation bayers so heißt
dieser mechanismus ist eine
psychologische bestätigungs falle die
allen menschen droht im internet wird
dieser psychologische effekt verstärkt
firmen wie facebook und google merken
was uns interessiert und gefällt und sie
geben uns mehr davon
der klimaskeptiker sieht immer mehr
nachrichten die seiner überzeugung
entsprechen andere argumente dringen
kaum noch durch eine filter blase
entsteht ein raum in dem wir immer nur
die gleichen stimmen hören denn was uns
in unserer ansicht bestärkt teilen wir
mit freunden und gleichgesinnten
so entsteht ein kreislauf der
bestätigung ja herr streuen können sie
das bestätigen dass das zugenommen hat
es ist auf jeden fall schlimm wenn man
kinder hat muss man sie frustriert sie
können fragen darf ich schokolade haben
und manchmal sagt man ja und man muss
hat man ein nicht vor dem essen so was
das ist ganz wichtig wenn jetzt diese
internetwelt uns immer mehr davon gibt
was wir angeblich wollen dann fällt mir
noch was anderes ein sektenchefs sekten
vorsteher gurus
die haben mit der zeit so viel macht
dass ihre jünger ertappten ihre anhänger
sich nicht mehr trauen ihnen schlechte
nachrichten zu überbringen
das heißt sie kriegen langsam ein
paranoides gefühl ich bin abgenabelt von
der welt und dann werden sie ziemlich
irrational
das muss schrecklich sein sie werden
fast künstlich psychotisch das war sie
keine kritik mehr hört ja genau weil
alles immer nur homogen positiv ist und
jetzt sind wir alle sagt ja also es geht
uns wissen ähnlich wir sollten uns mehr
frustrieren also wir brauchen wahrheit
subjektive wahrheit wir sollten nicht
nur bestätigung nazistische bestätigung
also in den spiegel schauen ist das
schon ein problem ständig aber was ist
in wahrheit wie weiß man welche theorie
war es und wie unterscheidet sich
letztlich das durch die frage in der
verschwörungstheorie von einer
wissenschaftlichen das würde ich noch
sagen zu ihrer erfahrung expertin für
hochbau statistik oder statik statik
dass es dann doch nichts letztlich wenn
man mit verschwörungstheoretikern
spricht sie können die argumente bringen
sie haben immer machen argument weil der
glaube ist wichtiger
und da war was ist welche wahrheit ist
wichtig oder warum wenn die noch ein
argument haben würde man noch das
vernünftige perspektive sagen dann haben
sie eben die besseren argumente und
letztlich haben sie recht
nein die filtern argumente in genau dem
sinne wie sie das was wir jetzt gerade
gesehen haben war ja eigentlich so die
sind neue medien filter blase eine
facebook oder bin ich mir nicht google
auf mache ich krieg nur noch werbung für
sachen die ich ohnehin schon mal gekauft
habe und so weiter aber das gab es ja
schon vorher und sekten sind ein sehr
gutes beispiel dafür dass die leute
sozusagen in einer kompletten eigenen
parallelwelt leben wo die die filterung
durch den sektenführer oder die anderen
mitglieder passiert und das kann man
sich natürlich auch geistig ohnehin
schon einrichten und überzeugte in der
wolle gefärbte verschwörungstheoretiker
ich habe das selber erlebt weil ich habe
mich mit diesen sachen beschäftigt und
hatte dann fakten und wir haben also
fakt gegen fakt geknallt
und natürlich irgendwann gemerkt die
nehmen nur die fakten auf die zu ihrer
bestätigung passen und der rest wird
wiederum ausgefiltert und das anders ja
also ich habe mich dafür interessiert
und eine zeit lang gedacht ich will
jetzt mal wissen wie das funktioniert
und wie plausibel dass auch wirklich ist
und ich habe viel gelernt und dann
irgendwann habe ich gesagt okay
nachdem ich mir alle fakten angeguckt
habe halte ich das für unplausibel aber
das andere ist die macht damit die
stärke und da muss man irgendwie ernst
nehmen dass das auch etwas ist und
vielleicht können sie das mal genauer
definieren was mit mythos mal sagen wir
mal verschwörungstheorien sind ein teil
von mir
die geschichte der außerirdischen die
uns besuchen ist ein anderer mythos das
loch ness der yeti das monster dass das
sind auch mit modernen bild und die
schließen natürlich an an andere alte
mythen hat gestern hat gab ein jubiläum
gehabt der zoologe aus der renaissance
da im grossmünster gar nicht gearbeitet
als kirchenmann
er hat sich aus der ganzen welt
holzschnitte von tieren schicken lassen
und sein tier buch dort gibt es eine
unsicherheit in sachen nashorn und eines
hat ein kapitel nasa ein kapitel
einhauen aber es hat bilder von
nachahmern untereinheit und bilder von
einhörnern unter nase
das ist eine interessante zeit kurz
nachher in der neuzeit wurden die
bemühten über tiere gekippt aus der
zoologie und jetzt tauchen sie wieder
auf in der sogenannten kryptozoologie
die überlebenden seien die city aber was
spielt die was spielen mythen jetzt für
eine rolle für diese negative diese
blasen electric etwas aus worauf wir
nicht verzichten
was das ist das möchte ich nicht so
schnell beantworten ich weiß es nicht da
war zum beispiel die auch welches
bedürfnis welches sehnsucht oder welcher
und welche vielleicht hat man erst mal
allein zu sein ist vielleicht die mode
ist schrecklich grauen habe
dann auch die hoffnung es könnten welche
kommen die was dämonisches raten wieder
ein angenehmes genießen an gruseln oder
dann die frage wer sind wir überhaupt
ein psychoanalytiker daniels die boni
hat man ich habe ihn gefragt was sind
die außerirdischen
er hat gesagt er soll bleiben
die frau also einer welche dies sind wie
wir aber anders
damit können wir uns sehen was wir sind
andere die ein bisschen verschieden sind
eine sehnsucht nach selbsterkenntnis
lässt
ok ich würde jetzt noch interessieren
oft wird ja gesagt und das klang schon
so ein bisschen an diese theorien sind
irgendwie nicht falsifiziert die sind
nicht wirklich widerlegbar sehen sie das
auch so
das dass die große schwäche ist von
solchen verschwörung der sie sind oft so
angelegt dass sie da wo man sie sie sind
ja also die von denen ich jetzt spreche
sind oft hyper fakten gesättigt aber
diese fakten werden so wie man ein
gegenargument gegen faktum bringt zum
beispiel dass der suppe der film noch
alle anzeichen dafür trägt dass er nicht
auch manipuliert ist es gibt sehr sehr
viele theorien darüber dass dieser film
als solcher manipuliert wurde und in st
das ist doch nicht plausibel und wer
könnte so etwas technisch machen auf dem
stand der 60er jahre und so weiter und
das heißt sie sind sie arbeiten mit dem
anschein von falsifiziert weil sie
tausende von fakten auf den tisch
knallen und wenn man aber falsifiziert
dann kommen sie mit einer extra fakten
kette und das ist also der verbuchen sie
so auch in ihrer faktizität immer weiter
um sich gegen falsifiziert barkeit
abzudichten
und wenn man sagt sozusagen das spricht
gegen die verschwörungstheorie dann
sagen die vielleicht dass das eigentlich
nur wegen ein cover up sagt wie gut die
inszenierung ist
also sie sind an falls die beziehung
nicht interessiert wissenschaftler schon
sondern sie wiederholen sie wiederholt
wiederholen die geschichte die
verschwörungstheorie immer wieder das
ist der zweck das meint sie mit diesem
denken ja ja sie kommen aber auch nicht
weiter in der bekämpfung der
verschwörung der weltverschwörung sie
gehen oft glaube ich nicht in die
politik oder wenn dann auf mich ziemlich
schrägen aber auch schon unterwandert
und die politik ist ja nur eine kulisse
und da man kann in die politik gehen
aber das nützt ja gar nichts also sie
die verschwörungstheorie dient auch dazu
die eigene passivität irgendwie zu
erklären sagen das ist ja ohnehin alles
sinnlos warum soll ich mich in der
demokratie engagieren wenn die
demokratie sowieso nur eine schein
landschaft ist hinter der irgendwelche
finsteren akteure die strippen ziehen
dann brauche ich mich doch auch nicht zu
engagieren
also sozusagen einen wissensvorsprung
und eine handlungs lähmungen die damit
dann aber auch legitimiert wird das
spricht derzeit gegen dieses
ohnmachtsgefühl also wenn man das doch
dass der grund ist wie man hat ein
ohnmachtsgefühle braucht aber nicht aus
dem sessel aufzustehen und so zu einem
teil der wissen denn dann hat man diese
erhöhung bei der letzten wahl in
frankreich vor ein paar tagen weiß nicht
genau wie die heißen legislative wegen
so etwas haben 50 prozent teilgenommen
die die anderen haben haben sich befragt
davon und jetzt sagen die die nicht
teilgenommen haben diese abstimmung geht
nicht den willen der wähler mit ja also
es ist schon fast ein bisschen
verschwörungstheoretiker sie hätten hat
wählen ist ja also wir sehen die die die
unterscheidung im detail ist wirklich
sehr sehr schwierig zu treffen das
zeigen auch debatten wie in der schweiz
die behaupten
historiker dann jede ganz zum beispiel
und sie frauen plädieren dafür dass wir
diese theorien ernst nehmen dass wir
verschwörungstheorien diese skeptische
denken ernst nehmen warum was können wir
denn lernen also das eine habe ich schon
gesagt verschwörungstheorien können auch
eine anleitung zum kritischen
hinterfragen von offiziellen wahrheiten
seien in der gewissen weil sie haben es
auch schon gesagt investigative
journalisten sind auch mikro
verschwörungs aufdecker
verschwörungstheoretiker und stoßen dann
eben oft auf etwas was auch so ein
kleiner seilschaft ist das andere was
ich ganz wichtig finde auch wenn ich
verschwörungstheorie viele
verschwörungstheorien irrsinnig absurd
finde müssen wir ernst nehmen dass sie
zirkulieren und verstehen warum sie
zirkulieren und sie nicht einfach nur
pathologie sieren oder sagen das ist
eine pathologie auch der
mediendemokratie daran glauben nur
idioten das sind sie haben es eben
gesagt große teile der wählerschaft die
viele von den tramp wählern in den usa
glauben an unterschiedliche
versatzstücke von verschwörungstheorien
ich glaube dass die populisten die wir
im moment erleben also diese diese neuen
formen von anti eu wieder erstarken von
national geist anti migration america
first und so weiter also diese diese
starken männer die diese kern sprüche
verbreiten gegen die eliten dass wir die
im grunde genommen auch auf ihre
verschwörungstheorie tischen anteile hin
betrachten müssen nicht alle
populistischen bewegungen sind
verschwörungstheoretiker aber ich glaube
verschwörungstheorien sind immer
populistisch und damit eigentlich auch
ein bestandteil von medien demokratien
und deshalb muss man sie als politisches
phänomen ernst nehmen und auch die
personen genau anschauen und nicht
einfach nur sie für dumpfbacken halten
die ungebildet sind oder so sondern
sagen was befriedigen diese
verschwörungstheorien wie werden die
zirkuliert und wie entstehen die
und diese filter blasen struktur ist
heute einfach sehr viel leichter
geworden durch die neuen medien die
seine rhetorische strategie zu sagen das
ist eine verschwörungstheorie also sowie
tromp das macht der zu wollen noch mal
ein eine wollte als verschwörungstheorie
das jetzt von leuten die selber
verschwörungstheorien verbreiten
das fact checking der traditionellen
medien die dann sagen nein das ist aber
nicht so nen hier wir haben die fakten
das wird dann wiederum denunziert als
verschwörungstheorie von jemandem wie
trump oder bei uns in österreich von hc
strache der auf einmal der selber
unglaublich viele falschmeldungen gegen
migranten und so weiter verbreitet und
wenn man die dann widerlegt und beweise
dafür bringt dann sagt er das sind fake
news also diese die vorwürfe der
verschwörungstheorie werden
zurückgespielt von den
verschwörungstheoretiker
das klingt jetzt also so aus während die
verschwörungstheoretiker frauen im
rechten lager politik angesiedelt das
kann man so nicht sagen
interessante frage ja linke
verschwörungstheorien gibt es natürlich
auch der staat bedeutet uns aus aber die
sind irgendwie simpler und weniger
dämonisch ist gewollt haben seither
haben die villa großkonzerns dann tut
sie auch lernen aber das kann man
leidenschaftslos festzustellen und die
linken verschwörungstheoretiker sind so
ein bisschen resigniert
die rechten sind aufgeregt und
gefährlich eigentlich kommt
wahrscheinlich jemand darauf an wen man
fragt ich habe meine hypothese aber ich
würde sagen man muss falsifizieren auch
wenn es nichts nützt
und gleichzeitig haben sie recht man
muss die verschwörungstheorien darauf
befragen was sich hinter ihnen für eine
haltung versteckt für eine situation der
menschen die sie pflegen oder weil
dahinter ist schon was eben eine
politische ohnmacht das gefühl
ich werde doch nicht gefragt ich bin
ausgeben muss dazu sagen dass
interessant ich möchte noch auf einen
anderen aspekt kommen
das ist ja auch experte für die zukunft
und sie sagen eigentlich sind wir heute
besessen von katastrophenszenarien dazu
kommt was ich das in hollywood an
diensten filmen aber hinter literatur
hängen die beiden dinge zusammen dass
wir haben mir einen boom der
verschwörungstheorien erleben wenn es
denn so ist und gleichzeitig ein bogen
dieser apokalyptischen vorstellungswelt
ja also historisch ist das ganz klar
miteinander verknüpft zum beispiel auch
also diese diese fiktion von der
jüdischen weltverschwörung entsteht in
einem moment wo ein massiver moderne
schock also um die jahrhundertwende 19
20 jahrhundert empfunden wird
wird also zunächst mal auch eher in
ländlichen gebieten weitergereicht und
und kommt dann sozusagen einigen
bewegungen wie zum beispiel die nazis
sehr zupass und wird dann von denen
weiterverbreitet und insofern kann man
sagen so ein apokalyptisches jetzt
zeitgefühl und die die die verbreitung
und und die popularität von
verschwörungstheorien das geht absolut
zusammen
heute sind die dinge natürlich
komplizierter und gleichzeitig medial
viel enger verknüpft und ich glaube wir
haben im moment ganz massiv das gefühl
die zukunft ist voller risiken und
unwägbarkeiten globalen maßstab sie
haben den klima skeptiker hier genannt
aber man also viel verbreiteter sind
natürlich die leute die mit gutem recht
große angst haben vor dem klimawandel
der sozusagen das gesamte natur gefüge
das lebens system unseres planeten
erschüttern wird und diese ich glaube
dieses zukunfts gefühl unsere welt
ändert sich in einer folge fundamentalen
in einer vollkommen unabsehbaren weise
führt wiederum zu einer grund an
die bei manchen leuten dann sozusagen
dadurch behandelt wird dass sie
versuchen greifbarere szenarien in die
welt zu setzen sei es nicht die natur
die sich fundamental ändert und unsere
enkel werden vielleicht nicht mehr an
den orten leben können an denen wir
jetzt leben oder unter den gleichen
bedingungen sondern sagen ja das sind
die multinationalen konzerne das ist
hillary clinton das sind die migranten
oder sonstwer der unsere welt
erschüttert also ich glaube es gibt so
eine tröstliche verschiebung auf
greifbarere probleme und anonymen
ereignissen wenig zutraut zu ihr weil
der klimawandel ist natürlich schwer wir
alle sind beteiligt den klimawandel zu
erzeugen und das heißt da kann man nur
schwer drahtzieher aber nennen um und
sorgt auch immer schuldig dabei herrscht
ein ich glaube mein buch die lust am
untergang also nicht wer das geschrieben
der titel ist sehr wichtig und ich denke
auch so armageddon vorstellungen beim
aufgeregten christen zum beispiel das
ist etwas auch sehr gemütliches wir sind
zeuge auch wenn wir vielleicht dabei
untergehen eines gewaltigen geschehens
das ist nazistisch rapp lifting das hebt
uns wir sind auch bis am schluss dabei
gewesen dann wären wir dann sozusagen
mit seiner bis zum schluss sind
wahrscheinlich nicht dabei sie habe ich
meine ja dass wir nach der nächsten
generation
er ist auch etwas das sie auch sagen das
ist nicht nur eine ausstellung sondern
auch eine wunschvorstellung das ist
apokalyptisch
ja ich glaube es gibt ein bedürfnis
danach sich diese diese unglaubliche
abstraktheit mit des klimawandels oder
dessen was man heute anthropozän nennt
es ist ja nicht nur klimawandel sind
ganz viele ökologische und
wirtschaftliche und und migrantische
probleme die wir haben und wir brauchen
konkrete szenarien und ich glaube die
haben in sich etwas ja vielleicht nicht
lustvolles aber befriedigen des
beruhigendes ich stelle mir vor dass
kommt auf mich zu und dann kann ich mir
überlegen wie wie sorge ich vor was kann
ich da kann ich eine versicherung
abschließen kann ich
im keller einlagern oder vielleicht eine
waffe unter dem kopfkissen vorrätig
halten also in dem moment wo ich ein
konkretes szenario habe kann ich habe
ich mehr eigene handlungsmacht wieder
gewonnen
vielleicht ich hätte noch eine frage an
sie und an die medien
das treibt mich wirklich um was können
eigentlich seriöse medien was können
auch wissenschaftler wie wir tun gegen
diese ja dieses paranoide mindset und
diese verbreitung von fake news und
verschwörungstheoretiker denken durch
die neuen populismus
ich finde das ganz schwierig weil die
bank in also fact checking seriöse
berichterstattung scheint dagegen in
einer gewissen weise kaum noch zu helfen
was tun zu stellen und wollte sie fragen
was tun
er muss jetzt rollen auf die bank man
muss trotzdem auch alleine schafft man
vertrauen ich glaube das ist der
entscheidende begriff vertragen wissen
schon der verschwörungstheoretiker nicht
lächerlich machen nein das wird man
sehen man muss sie ernst nehmen und
wahrscheinlich muss man weiterhin mit
ihnen diskutieren
mein eindruck ist dass die mediale
situation heute so ist das
verschwörungstheoretiker anders als das
früher war gar nicht mehr diskutieren
wollen
die sagen auch es mir doch egal dann
gibt's das halt nicht den
kinderpornografie-ring im keller der
pizzeria irgendwas den dreck am stecken
hat die hillary clinton hat der dies hat
er das und obama ist sowieso ein
indonesia aber das heißt doch die
wahrheit ist uns gar nicht mehr wichtig
es ist sie reden auch das ist heute wird
bullshit gerät geschwätz ist egal
letztlich ist egal was stimmt oder nicht
man möchte bestimmte personen angreifen
mit bestimmten vorwürfen
ob die dann stecken ist gar nicht so
entscheidend
wir haben eine verschwörungstheorie die
heftige klagen wir haben
wissenschaftliche gegenargumente die
nicht interessieren denn
verschwörungstheoretiker
wir haben noch etwas anderes das finde
ich sehr schwer zu formulieren es ist
vielleicht die wahrheit das subjekt wir
müssen darauf eingehen wie sich der
verschwörung verschwörungstheoretiker
fühlt in seiner existenz in seinem leben
und vielleicht wenn wir ihm das gefühl
geben können ist mir klar warum du das
glauben muss so wie du dich fühlst
aber das ist sowieso logi sierung dieses
das macht man doch mit nun mit der
einstein hätte man das auch nicht
gemacht wenn er seine
relativitätstheorie erfindet zu sagen
das ist keine pathologischen und so es
bedeutet ist eine relative relativierung
dieser dieser verschwörungstheorie
ethischen wahrheit man sagt jede
wahrheit dieser art hat mit ihr zu tun
auch mit dir als als einzel mensch aber
die wollen doch auf die sache eben und
zeigen es gibt die und die argumente die
dafür sprechen führen jedoch zu ich bin
kein das ist sehr herablassend kann ich
mir vorstellen das gefühl ich war den
größten teil des letzten jahres in
amerika und ich habe kaum jemanden
finden können dir mehr dass das mindset
eines trump wählers erklären kann und
dass das war meine filter blase ich mein
new york und in new york waren alle für
kranken und ich habe lange gebraucht und
auch die traditionellen guten medien die
ich gelesen habe die haben mir nichts
darüber sagen können warum leute in west
virginia trump wählen und was für
probleme die haben und warum die gute
gründe haben die sind nicht alle
verrückt sondern die erwarten etwas
bestimmtes und denen gefällt etwas an
auch an dieser selbstinszenierung dieses
mannes und dass das kann man nicht
pathologie sind sondern muss erst mal
verstehen wo stehen die bekommen die
hier was für probleme haben die sie
haben jobs verloren es gab wirklich
einen wirtschaftlichen niedergang in
bestimmten regionen in usa und den gibt
es auch in europa und die populistischen
bewegungen knüpfen an in england in
österreich in ungarn an leute die
wirklich probleme haben und ich glaube
wir müssen diese probleme besser
verstehen um sozusagen mit diesen leuten
in einen anderen dialog kommen zu können
als den über schuldige migranten
schuldige großbanken oder schuldige
reptil louis de oder also all diese
diesen quatsch leute die an chemtrails
glauben sind oft krank und fühlen sich
krank da müssen wir verstehen woran sind
die eigentlich krank was macht die so
krank sind vielleicht unserer meinung
nach nicht die chemtrails aber die die
leute haben deutlich empfundene
subjektive probleme die man nicht
einfach nur subjektiv ihren kann und die
verschwörungstheorien sind symptome
daher als gesellschaftliche krisen aber
auch persönliche hab ich gesagt nein da
bin ich vielleicht weil ich wollte nur
sagen er ist ein äußerst erfolgreicher
geschäftsmann und lässt sich von
niemandem etwas sagen auch nicht von
hohen beamten in meisten haus- und
zweiter satz ich der trailer könnte auch
so werden und was ist wichtig diese
fantasien erfand er kann das auch sehr
oft mit meiner mannschaft von american
dream
aber diese wird das verschwörungstheorie
tische denken dass zirkulieren von fake
news und diese populisten sind ja also
mittlerweile überall auf der welt am
erstarken auf den philippinen in ungarn
also ich habe es vor der haustür mit der
ungarischen regierung und die frage ist
eigentlich oder der wechselt was ist im
moment los was passiert da gerade das
ist das was ich verstehen möchte
gleichzeitig sagen die uns ihr seid
sozusagen teil dieser verschwörung der
systemmedien der lügen presse wir sind
selbst vertreten oder und ich meine
manchmal denke ich das schon irgendwie
putin und erdogan permanent negativ
dargestellt werden so ein bisschen
verdächtig müsste man mal andere medien
angucken und so weiter also es ist ja
nicht einfach so dass man das wegwischen
könnte ließen vor und psychoanalyse
beschreibt den menschen als gespalten in
einem teil der der glauben will
phantasmen hat von der eigenen größe zum
beispiel der nazismus und einen anderen
teil das realitätsprinzip der versucht
realistisch zu sein und selbstkritisch
und dass ich wenn man muss zeigen dass
die realität mehrheit in diesem sinne
einen wert hat dass man besser
funktioniert wenn man nicht nur glaubt
was passt was was das tröstet tröstet
wir sind schon fast am ende dieser
stunde zum schluss noch eine persönliche
frage bei welcher verschwörungstheorie
würde sie haben wenigsten überraschen
wenn sie war bei ihnen herrscht heute
das ist eine lange liste
ich bin ich habe gesagt ich habe zwei
standbeine oder ich bin ein skeptiker
und ich bin eben auch ein gläubiger und
ich verrechne das immer gegner einander
so forsche ich indem ich mich beobachte
und da muss ich schon sagen also ein
haufen fahren die geschichten mit den
außerirdischen mit roswell und so dass
wir die mir sehr gefallen aber der
andere teil sagte vergiss es wie
schützen sie sich selbst vor diesen
trend geben es wäre zu schön um wahr zu
sein dass das hat zu sehr den charakter
eines mythos seines ich sag jetzt mal
masturbation das also sie träumen aber
wirklich von dem alien in ihrem
schlafzimmer das wird mir klar aber ich
habe so auf einer sms sehr ist die messe
habe ich so ein blatt gekauft mit
symbolen und er hat gesagt hatten sie
manchmal kopf wiederverkäufer und dann
habe ich gesagt ja das kommt vor ort hat
er gesagt das sind die aliens die
versuchen bei ihnen anzudocken und mit
diesem blatt können sie das nicht hoffe
ich dass ich jetzt besser
er streute frau in vielen herzlichen
dank für das gespräch
ja nächste woche spricht meine kollegin
barbara bleisch mit der philosophie
beate rösler über unsere freiheit und
fragt wie viel selbstbestimmung braucht
es für ein gelingendes leben können das
tragen einer burka oder sechs aber hat
und wirklich freiwillig sein und warum
ist es überhaupt so wichtig dass wir
selber über unser leben entscheiden
können und jetzt gleich zeit die
sternstunde kunst in vielen dass wolken
schatten bot ein porträt über den
schweizer schriftsteller gerhard maier
der diese woche den hundertsten
geburtstag gefeiert hätte
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]